oh it's so nice to see your gentleman
with you this evening i'm very pleased
they're here your boy is so big now yeah
oh my gosh it's just like that and just
like that yeah
what is now the right time sarah jessica
for this series to come back in this way
um i i don't i don't know that there is
a right or wrong time i think for us for
michael patrick king and myself and and
then and moving over to the next most
important conversations which were
cynthia and kristen
we felt excited about
the kind of stories that we were
interested in telling and we found a
home again at hbo and so we were
encouraged that
this year or next year it just felt
appropriate somehow that that we had
left these women
and we were curious as to you know about
where they were and who they were and
what was their life like and who were
they now surrounded by and it gave us a
lot of opportunities as you know
to make the family larger and start
telling news stories so
time being right or wrong i think is
more about what what is inspiring to us
or what was at the time and it has been
10 years since we've seen these
characters so did you slip back into
carrie just as easily as you you know
unfortunately had left previously but
was she easy to capture again especially
that first table read the table read was
just hugely joyous everybody
surprisingly i think the men were even
more sentimental than the women there
were more tears from our men
than there were for the women i think
because we'd also been talking so we had
stayed more connected
the table read was fun and joyous and
buoyant and i think hugely meaningful
just to simply be all in a room it was
the first table read in new york
where people were entirely vaccinated so
it was a coming together after
a very complicated and terrifying
large amount of time so there was that
as well
um but i think actually the doing of
every day figuring out you know who
carrie is who is charlotte who is
miranda putting that back together is
probably not quite as simple as some
might think because you may recall how
they sound and walk and talk but more so
who are they now and what has time given
them and
how do you reveal that and what do they
dress like and what matters to them so
there's a glass that's jp absolutely not
it's a mere hours away
i cannot wait for it and you're keeping
secrets this long give us a taste of how
the fashion has evolved obviously
fashion was a character in the previous
series in the movies i think it's best
for me to let the work of molly rogers
and danny santiago who are with us from
the beginning
tell that story and it will become
abundantly clear that like
many people
time and experiences and cities and
environment and circumstances tend to
dictate
who you are when you walk out the door
and i think this is no different we have
some new faces in here as you've
mentioned so how are they spicing up the
lives of the three best friends the ogs
i think there is spice there is
diversity of thought and feeling and
perspective i think there is richness in
people whose stories we sort of fill up
before we get to meet them on screen but
they make our lives more interesting the
stories that we get to tell you know how
we're exchanging conversation and
intimacies and
how we're relying on one another
it's just exciting and and
we couldn't have gotten luckier but not
just on screen but in the writer's room
equally so
the new group of people that joined us
the group the kind of writers that
wanted to be there it's just
i have to tell you it it was just
magical the crew
our dp
i mean from start to finish for everyone
in the group and we see new faces uh
behind the scenes in front of the camera
there will be one friend absent samantha
of course will fans have will fans be
given a satisfying storyline as to her
whereabouts i mean i can't speak for the
audience they have to have that
experience themselves i think what's
wonderful is that we have a writer and
actors who love that character who love
telling stories and being in
situations and environments with
samantha
and we're really lucky we have those
memories and that experience but really
what's missing is willie garson that's
the person that's missing this was a
person that was lost far too soon who
was going to play a significant role and
that's the kind of
space you can't fill